oui d'abord moi je voudrais saluer son
courage parce que déjà c'est une
lanceuse d'alerte elle est pas obligée
de le dire elle aurait pu rester dans
son coin rien dire et faire troué pr
prendre les 30000 c'est pas c'est pas
c'est pas après que moi ça déconne je me
dis que ça déconne de rembourser 31000 €
qu'on lui rembourse ok pas de problème
mais on rembourse pas d'autres choses il
y a d'autres choses qui sont pas
remboursées on voit des gens dans la rue
il y a les cendants François Hollande
les avait appelé les sendants par
exemple il y a des gens qui ont travaill
toute leur vie on le rembourse pas leurs
dents à eux et pourtant c'est pour
s'alimenter les dents donc c'est aussi
un problème esthétique 'im mais c'est ce
que je suis en TR d'exquer non non l'
nempêche pas l'autre sauf que sauf que
si on rembourse 300 on fait aussi pour
l'autre moi ce que j'entends c'est que
on donne tout le temps aux gens je parle
pas pour elle on a souvent tendance à
donner aux gens qui ne travaillent pas
qui ne montrent pas de bons message et
on sacrifie toujours les gens qui
bossent quelqu'un qui bosse qui doit se
faire Rember ses frais médicau on lui
dit si tuas pas de mutuel c'est mort
pour tu imagines avec les 8 milliards tu
imagines avec 8 milliard de fraudon F
pas d'autre sujet que de s'attaquer aux
personnes je
m'que je m'attaque pas elle de la
question des 30000 € si on me demande
est-ce que est-ce que est-ce que vous
êtes choqué je dis oui la polémique je
la comprends c'est une polémique est-ce
que tu dois comprendre la polémique je
la comprends parce que tu as des gens en
France il peuvent pas se soigner parce
qu'ils ont des problèmes de reins des
problèmes de dos des problèmes de jambes
ils vont travailler en boîant ils vont
travailler sans dents il y en a qui
c'est les sans dents c'est 9
10000 it laiss crever aussi les
personnes trans je dis pas qu'
laiss par prtution prenons les problèmes
dans l'ordre je ne dis pas qu'il faut
pas rembourser son intervention je dis
que avant tout quelqu'un qui travaille
pour la France quelqu'un qui donne les
bons messages pour la France et N qui
aussi des impôts qui donne les bons
messages si on la rembourse 30000 il y a
pas de raison qu'on remourse pas les aut
je suis
d'accord c'est pour ça que je comprends
la polémique non ma P je la laisse je la
laisse ma PC parce que je comprends la
polémique merci Monsieur le problème
enfin quand j'entends on peut pas
rembourser les uns et ne pas rembourser
les autres excusez-moi on est quand même
en train de parler de pognon quoi de
budget le budget est pas extensible vous
dites qu'on dépense 8 il y a 8 milliards
de fraudes il y a 800 milliards
effectivement de dépenses sociales mais
le problème c'est queon a encore des
besoins on parle de vie humaine on parle
pas de d'argent attendez excusez-moi
c'est pas person suici ce qu' est en
train de dire c'est que c'est
attendez d'abord c'est pas vital et dans
ce caslà si vous voulez vous avez vous
avez des non mais attendez vous avez des
gens qui s'ouffrent alors si on
rembourse des dysphories de genre
pourquoi ne rembours-on pas des
dysphories chromatiques imaginez par
exemple imaginez qu'un Blanc se sent
noir ou qu'un Noir se sent blanc
pourquoi est-ce qu'on rembourse mais
c'est pas un jugement moral encore une
fois ce n'est pas encore un jugement
moral moi j'ai rien contre vos choix
personnel et votre vie personnelle non
mais même vos orientations je n'ai rien
contre ça juste qu
je Jean-Michel dans un instant vous
allez parlé il m'a dit m' dit un truc
ouf m' dit mon intervention va faire
date c'est peut-être un peu excessif
c'est un problème qui enfin je vais
parler de choses qui me touche voilà
d'accord personnellement d'accord
paulski euh alors moi déjà je tiens à
dire que j'adore la communauté LGBT
transur et cetera euh je sais que ça
doit être super compliqué de nettre dans
le mauvais corps mais en fait jeangeant
un peu la vie de de Raymon du coup il y
a plein de gens qui ont des maladie du
coup mortell comme le cancer et cetera
et eux ilsc remours non il y a plein de
qui sont pas remboursés quasiment tous y
a quand même plein de qui sont pas
remboursés et qui tu as payé des impôts
qui tuas payé des impôts j'aurais aimé
que ce soit remboursé pour pour vous
comme pour les gens qui ont des maladies
par mortell mais qu à choisir j'aurais
préféré bah payer pour les mourants mais
pourois person des suici ou s'aututiler
comme ça ça aurait été un tout petit peu
j'aimerais Nina et après j'aimerais
Jean-Michel mer parce qu'il a dit que ça
allait faire date déjà moi j'ai c'est
pas lanceuse d'alerte moi j'ai fait
cette vidéo déjà c'était pour répondre à
une abonnée pour expliquer et informer
qu'on peut être remboursé par la
Sécurité Sociale et qu'on est pas obligé
en France d'aller se prostituer par
exemple au bois de Boulogne pour payer
ses opérations parce qu'il faut le dire
aussi il y a plein de femmes trans qui
font ça le problème bien évidemment
c'est pas les femmes trans mais c'est
bien le système que qui est mal fait
parce que M moi je suis d'accord he que
c'est pas qu'il y a des inégalités mais
on y est pour rien et ce que je voulais
dire aussi c'est que les opérations
elles sont pas remboursées
automatiquement il y a c'està-dire que
c'est pas on va s'inscrire à l'hôpital
on dit je veux changer de sexe bah
écoutez demain vous aurez une poitrine
plus plus le C ça il y a un long
parcours il y a un parcours
psychiatrique psychologique moi entre le
moment où je me suis inscrite et le
moment où je me suis fait opérer de la
vaginoplastie s'est écoulé 8 ans en fait
et pendant les 8 ans j'ai quand même eu
les épaules il y en a elles abandonnent
avant elles se suicid avant il y en a
aussi qui qui qui s tellement long le
parcours public pour avoir les
opérations remboursées qu'il y en a qu's
abandonnent et qui vont payer leurs
opérations en Thaïlande ou je ne sais où
mais du coup c'est oui ça peut être
remboursé mais ça se fait pas comme ça
quoi c'est h ch c'est pas un cho dis il
y a des gens qui disent et voilà c'est
ça c'est la grande question y a des gens
qui disent le cancer n'est pas un choix
par contre c'est beaucoup moins un choix
c'est ce qu'il disent c'est ce qu'il dis
sur les r person ontnaelles ont été
remboursé le cancer pas un choix il y a
beaucoup de gens qui disent que c'est
scandaleux sur les réseaux Jean-Michel
oui déjà je dire à Hugo qui disait que
c'était peinut c'était tellement peu de
personnes c'était pas important en
disant çaé par 10 le nombre de personnes
qui veulent changer donc c'est un
problème qui prend de l'ampleur même si
c'est encore par 3
201 c'est une question de priorité dans
idéal évidemment que tout quelqu'un qui
veut soit aidé pour changer de sexe j'ai
aucun problème sauf qu'il y a des
priorités aujourd'hui les priorités pour
moi elles ne sont pas là j'ai deux
exemples qui je vais te dire pour mod
m ton
inter sujet qui m'ont touché
personnellement voilà j'ai grandi à
Épinal mon ami d'enfance j'ai trois amis
d'enfance l'un est mort la nuit du
Nouvel An voilà il a eu fait un
infarctus il appelit les les secours les
secours voulaient venir faute de moyens
il y avait pas assez d'ambulance ils ont
fait pass santé il est mort il est
décédé cette nuit là du 31 décembre
voilà ça m'a beaucoup peiné 5 jours
après la mère de mon deuxème confat
d'enfance glisse sur une plaque de
verglas à Épinal dans les vuges
commotion cérébrale elle transporte
l'hôpital faute de moyens toujours on
l'a fait passanté sur un lit dans le
couloard de l'hôpital pendant 5 he au
moment où on fait le le enfin le scanner
il est trop tard pour l'opérer elle
décède une heure après donc je suis
désolé donc que les opération sont
importantes pour vous je suis d'accord
mais il y a des gens qui souffrent
d'Alzheimer ne sont pas remboursés
Alzheimer c'est aussi une priorite
gr pré
etarum 20 à 40% des gens qui se font qui
chent de sexe par plus jeun qui veulent
rechanger
dans je vais vous dire le gros gros
problème je vous dire le gros gros
problème et je le dis devant toi Nina le
gros gros problème et je vois les
réactions sur les raisons le le point
névralgique de cette affaire c'est que
pour les
gens il pensent que c'est un caprice pr
ils se disent pour eux c'est pas
prioritaire Alzheimer oui c'est
prioritaire et en fait c'est ça
l'histoire je te jure et c'est pour ça
que les gens tu vas voir le sondage je
pense que le sondage il je pense que le
sondage il VO VO voilà
faut
Pasch c'est
pas pour la plart des
g
voil
com
deorter les inégalité en matière de
traitement de santé moi je trouve ça un
peu fort comprendi jeich je dire elle y
est absolument pour
rien tu prends tu prends la
problématique par ce
côté juste
question question
question non mais vous vous dites que
c'est pas un choix donc on comprend que
c'est une c'est une maladie ou un
trouble mais le problème c'est que quand
on dit que les transgenres ont une
maladie ou un trouble on dit on les
stigmatise donc on on comprend pas très
bien en fait soit c'est une maladie soit
c'est une maladie dans ce CASL cette
maladie doit être diagnostié par
psychiatre donc vous devez passer chez
un psychiatre or C cette
obligation cette obligation non mais en
2023 cette obligation a été levée donc
en fait c'est ça ce que je c'est que
d'un côté d'un côté on tend à normaliser
le processus de changement de genre et
en même temps on rembourse on le
rembourse Aure de la sécurité sociale
donc c'estadctoire côé là s'il vous
plît dis je vous dis ce que je l non
mais c'est bon je vous dire je voudrais
m'adresser à Nina regardez Nina il y a
beaucoup de de réactions comme celle que
je vais vous dire c'est à cause de cette
femme c'est à cause que la sécurité
sociale ne rembouche pas assez le reste
qu'est-ce que vous répondez aux gens qui
disent c'est ça parce que c'est ça c'est
dur c'est à cause de cette femme bah pas
du tout pas du tout en fait de pointer
du doigt les personnes transur c'est
complètement injuste et c'est juste à
partiser la haine ça fait rien d'autre
parce que moi bah j suis pour rien et en
plus comme on disait la transidentité ça
ça représente un grain de sable dans le
désert enfin c'est c'est rien par
rapportobie par cont la transobie est un
paré en faend
VI parler Nina elle est là pour ça
laissz parler Nina Nina allez-y la vidéo
qu'on a partagé sur les réseaux sociaux
depuis plusieurs jours à part pour
ratiser la haine c'est pour parce qu'en
fait ça fait c'est pas de la politique
c'esti tout ça c'est juste polémique
c'est enfin moi j'y suis absolument pour
rien et M moi et mais moi je suis la
première à dire que oui il y a des
choses qui ne sont pas normales il y a
30 ans on aurait fait le même sondage
est-ce que c'est un choix pour
l'homosexualité il y aurait eu ça prend
du temps ça va prendre du temps mais ce
qui est bien c'est que tu continues à
essayer faut pas lâcher et des gens
commean un jour peut-être
comprendront je pe
répondre moi encore une fois c'est pas
un jugement moral que je porte moi j'ai
rien nonend moi j'ai rien contre vous et
j'ai rien contre votre orientation tout
ça
va parfait moi j'ai pas de
problèmeientation
seir
uneem vous souffrez d'une dysphorie de
genre oui ou
non vous avez sentez pas en adéquation
avec votre avec votre
corér que je dis c'est que moi ce que ce
qui me choque mais comme tous les
Français c'est que je suis contribuable
je ne veux pas je ne veux pas que notre
argent serve à ça
exc
je vais vous l un aree je l un areeet
merci Madame merci Madame ben je vais l
un autre tweet en France on ne rembourse
pas les couches pour un parkinsonien en
fauteuil roulant mais on a des sous pour
changer de sexe qu'est-ce vous répond à
ça bah je réponds que toujours pareil
faut pas hiérarchiser les souffrances et
qu'encore une fois j'y suis pour rien et
que il y a des personnes trans aussi qui
se suicide on est dans on est en 2023 on
est dans un pays développé dans une
société moderne et la santé mentale ça
doit être
aussi cet argument mais malheureusement
il y a une étude qui vient de sortir
pour dire que les personnes qui ont
changé de sexe ont plus de tendan
suiciireux qui n pas
changé mer en tout d'avo ave
nous bravo à vous parce
que qu'est-ce qu'il a qu'est-ce qu'il a
non rien non moi juste le gouvern par
roulant non mais tu as des en faute
roulant on pas de
fauteuil déjà mais quand vous pensez par
exemple la tension artérielle a été a
été déclassée des maladies de des
infections de longue durée donc on peut
pas si vous voulez des choses qui sont
aussi importantes mais le problème c'est
qu'on a des moyens on a des moyens
limités on peut pas tout faire voilà le
problèmeon arrêtera de les rembourser
que tout d'un coup la tension artérielle
reviendra dans sera bien inspiré de
c'est orientation
seelleéta
maladie arrrêtez de parler sur
les g vous
plaît c'est maladie alors de quo est-
que c'est maladie TR trble mal trble est
malade je suis désolé la de Gen en effet
tu asoup sourir je
contment expment vous
exp des gens disent que
Scand monsieur allezy les gens ne sont
pas encore prêts pour comprendre donc ça
ch dans
le ce que disait RM ce qu'a dit pa ce
qu'a dit Jean-Michel je suis d'accord
j'aimerais bien que tout le monde
puisse c'est pas en sacrifiant une
partie des personnes qui ont la chance
de pouvoir survivre que qu'on va aider
les
autrr ours
a en cas de d transition est-ce qu'il fa
tu pense qu'il faut aussi rembourser la
Secur parce que lorsque tu regardes les
chiffres aux États-Unis contrairement à
ce que tu dis il y a en ce moment c'est
en train de revenir qu'il y a beaucoup
de trans qui sont en train de faire tu
dis beaucoup mais faut parler de façon
précise beaucoup c'est
quoi merci n d'avoir aveous merci n dans
un instant on va faire un point c'est la
guerre entrenergieil plaî c'est la
arrêtez